[Music]
restoring an item back to its original
state is a tedious and delicate process
at a high price point and the stakes are
even higher watch 10 restoration experts
transform designer goods such as sharpie
stained chanel bags dog bitten louboutin
shoes and worn out louis vuitton wallets
back to new
each artisan has their own way of
restoring these luxury goods
[Music]
jerry gallagher has been repairing
luxury handbags for over 30 years
this three thousand dollar chanel gst
was accidentally burned by a candle
[Music]
jerry replaces the damaged leather on
the back pocket of the bag with caviar
leather
[Music]
this is the same type of leather it was
originally made with
[Music]
once the burn section is replaced jerry
stitches the bag back together making
sure the sewing needle falls into the
original stitch holes
[Music]
[Music]
rio is the owner of kim's shoe and bag
repair
he is restoring a pair of chanel ballet
flats
he starts by removing the heel plates
with an opener
then he makes new rubber soles and glues
them on
the suede on the shoes has faded so it
is being re-dyed
handbag clinic restores designer
handbags and shoes
this white chanel gst was drawn on with
sharpie
chloe an artisan at handbag clinic
starts by using a special ink remover to
contain the spread of the ink
[Music]
she then color matches paint to the
original color of the bag
color matching is important for blending
the restored parts with the original
chloe airbrushes it on lightly ensuring
that the texture of the leather is
maintained
[Music]
[Music]
rhaego brothers shoe and leather repair
restore shoes and leather goods
these one thousand dollar louboutins
were badly chewed up by a dog
the team removes and rebuilds the entire
upper part of the shoe
[Music]
they heat up new patent leather so that
it becomes more malleable and stretch it
over the upper part of the shoe
[Music]
then they reattach the platform
[Music]
heath potter is a professional cobbler
and a co-founder of potter and sons the
owner of these ferragamo loafers wore
the soles all the way through
heath replaces the outsole with german
pit tanned leather
it's long lasting and waterproof
to finish the process he stitches the
shoes and puts them onto a press
[Music]
vincent rowe jr is the owner of vince's
village cobbler
the famous red painted bottoms of these
louboutins have worn out
[Music]
vincent glues on a rubber sole protector
to add the red color back on
it will last much longer than the
original red paint
[Music]
daniel james from handbag clinic is
restoring a louis vuitton vanity case
the interior lining has deteriorated
from years of use
[Music]
he makes patterns using old pieces and
replaces them with pigskin leather
[Music]
the metal corners on the case have worn
out
daniel uses a special electricity
conducting pen to replate the metal
[Music]
jerry gallagher is restoring a chanel
classic flap bag
it was severely burned by an
incandescent light bulb
he cuts off only the damaged leather in
order to preserve most of the original
bag
[Music]
he creates a new piece with caviar
leather
[Music]
he skies the leather until it's paper
thin
when he lays the piece onto the bag the
transition between the original leather
and the new leather is seamless
bag remake studio in shown in japan
repairs designer bags and accessories
the leather on this louis vuitton wallet
has become discolored from heavy use
the artist color matches the wallet and
slowly paints over the faded areas
the leather on the edges is peeling
since it's in the most commonly touched
areas
it's sealed using an edge coat
[Music]
this will help protect the corners from
further peeling and damage
rio is restoring a pair of 600 gucci
sneakers
[Music]
the metallic green panel on the back of
the shoes is peeling
rio uses leather glue and an owl to glue
the peeled areas back on
he also uses a tiny paint brush to fill
in faded areas on the panel
to finish the job he goes over the
sneakers with white paint to touch up
any scuffed areas
[Music]
you